avec moi maintenant notre analyse michel
c'est auger est notre chef de bureau à
ottawa emmanuelle latraverse emmanuel
j'ai commencé avec vous est-ce que c'est
très habituel de voir des attaques comme
ça d'un premier ministre envers un
premier et provinciales en règle
générale pendant les campagnes
électorales aux temps de laisser les
chefs fédéraux faire leur campagne
on sent même pas trop me rappelez vous
par ailleurs la campagne et b6 anything
de conservatisme de danny williams
contre stephen harper voudrait que les
conservateurs en font encore les frais
des années plus tard ne vous dire que le
torchon brûle entre libéraux et
conservateurs en ontario ce qui est de
remarquable c'est que kathleen wynne a
quand même gagné gouvernement un mandat
majoritaire qui appelle le nom elle a
augmenté les appui envers son parti en
faisant campagne entre autres sur cet
enjeu des pensions qui est au coeur du
litige pourrait que les conservateurs
semble faire le pari qu'en bout de ligne
tout ce crêpage de chignon ça va passer
au dessus de la tête des électeurs et
que ceux ci vont voter avec avec leur
poche avec les baisses d'impôts et
cetera un peu comme si les conservateurs
croient que leur prend leur leurs plans
la stratégie de 2006 2008 2011 va
fonctionner dans l'environnement
politique de 2015 michel est ce que
c'est très habituel c'est pas très
habituel il faut pas oublier une chose
les en dehors du québec les partis sont
les mêmes quand on est membre du parti
libéral en aimant au provincial et au
fédéral
alors monsieur un peu très clairement
fait le pari que l'électorat
conservateur de l'ontario m pas madame
wayne m pense aux plans de pension
provincial est par ailleurs justin
trudeau peut pas non plus allé trop fort
avec madame wayne parce qu'il ya
d'autres dossiers qui sont impopulaires
la privatisation d'âge juan de la
société d'électricité
il ya des conflits avec les professeurs
donc le pari de monsieur harper c'est de
dire bon je vais mobiliser mon monde
metropcs les conservateurs et utiliser
madame wang pour faire ça c'est une
stratégie qui peut marcher
par contre on le voit souvent à linverse
on n'attaque pas le problème mais quand
le premier ce provincial et ben
populaire puis que le chef veut faire
campagne
il aime beaucoup ça à voir le chef de
ses côtés on voit plus l'inversé que
fugace que ce qu'on voit actuellement
on vous parlait de justin trudeau il ya
aussi quand on parle d' attaques de ton
il ya aussi ce temps de monsieur harper
envers justin trudeau qui fait
sourciller quand même à emmanuel oui
parce que généralement ils ont volé des
adversaires campagne électorale les
chefs politiques pour preuve d'un
certain respect de certains et décorum
les uns envers les autres monsieur était
elle madame le t elle on s'appelle
thomas mulcair juste être dos on a
marqué depuis le début de cette campagne
que monsieur à peu a pris l'habitude
fait référence aux chiens aux chiffres
libéral comme étant tout simplement
justin c'était même dimanche avec mme
royal je voulais juste à l'écouté justin
n'a tout simplement pas prêts et nous
caire et son parti poursuit toujours
leur idéologie socialiste et
protectionnisme ça c'est révélateur
quand même oui je vous dirais que une
stratégie derrière ça de la part des
conservateurs ce qu'on veut faire c'est
des peines dont vous l'avez trouvé où on
fait ça me moquais ottomane comme étant
un politicien de carrière et caetera et
à l'égard de monsieur trudeau
officiellement monsieur harper s'est
fait poser la question aujourd'hui est
un polar très content et d'écouté il il
vit roule même pour référence à leurs
chefs comme étant juste est pourquoi
nous on ferait pas une tentative la dent
d'essayer de le marginaliser davantage
utile disent qu'il n'est pas prêt comme
s'il ne peut pas être dans la cour des
grands mais monsieur maingain aussi fait
référence à son adversaire libéral comme
étant le chef du troisième parti mais en
après midi vous allez voir le porte
parole de la campagne conservatrice en
art remis en répondant à une question
sur les attentes envers le débat de
demain ait un café c'est quand même
quelque chose c'est très pape ans 200 m
dos à michel ou et puis on n'est qu'au
troisième jour de la campagne il faut
pas l'oublier
alors depuis trois jours les députés npd
sont les pires de l'histoire du canada
ça c'est ce qui me fait un peu lundi il
a dit l'opposition vont nous être dans
une récession permanente les deux partis
d'opposition et a fait des comparaisons
avec la grèce
il a attaqué madame naples est aussi la
nouvelle première ministre de l'alberta
et le bouquet est arrivé aujourd'hui
dans une publicité négative on indique
qu'un thomas mulcair est un politicien
professionnel
si stephen harper dit que thomas mulcair
est un politicien professionnel cw
accusé mcdonald's de faire de la
malbouffe là ça m'a pas aidé dit l'un ni
l'autre
alors elle m'a donné le danger les
canadiens sont d'habitude déjà assez
polis il n'aime pas trop ces bagarres de
rue là les gros il ya un risque sur la
façon parce que les canadiens justement
aime pas trop ces bagarres de vue là les
limites des militants politiques
raffolent de ça mais il a besoin d'aller
un peu plus loin que ça il faut à un
moment donné il y aura sans doute un
certain nombre de faux que ce groupe qui
vont lui dire de calmer ses ardeurs
comme vous diriger son troisième jour de
cette campagne